ever heard of the hyperbaric chamber
smith plastic surgery offers this new
state-of-the-art technology
for those in need of accelerated
recovery and just overall healing here's
how it works
[Music]
hi i'm dr lane smith here at the smith
plastic surgery institute and
i'd like to talk to you a little bit
about the hyperbaric chamber and what it
does and how it's used
you may have heard about it from tom
brady who feels like it helps improve
his
in his performance and so he's a he's an
avid a proponent
of the hyperbaric chamber and we have a
hyperbaric chamber here
what does the hyperbaric chamber
actually do
well this is the thing oxygen is what
makes your cells run it's like gasoline
for your car okay and obviously we don't
breathe
your cells don't run and you have a big
problem hemoglobin is actually very
efficient for carrying oxygen so oxygen
is carried in your blood on hemoglobin
and hemoglobin does a really good job
it carries at about 94 percent full so
if you increase the oxygen that a per
person breathes
you actually don't increase the blood
oxygen carrying capacity doesn't get any
better because it's already maxed out
but if you put that oxygen under
pressure the oxygen will actually
dissolve directly
into the bloodstream and in that way you
actually get an
increase in oxygen delivered to cells
so this is very important remember that
cells use the oxygen for power so
when the cells get more oxygen they can
do more building they can do more
recovering they can do those kind of
things
also there are places that get blocked
as we get older the small blood vessels
get blocked
oxygen you know the blood cells can't
get through and no oxygen gets there and
that tissue can die or be damaged or be
hurt
but if we can stick the oxygen under
pressure directly in the blood serum
it can actually leak through those
places where blood cells can't go
and feed it oxygen and help those places
grow and recover
so here you know we'll use it for
patients you know for face lifts
to decrease the bruising and help help
the flaps heal quicker
patients with breast lifts breast
reductions
will help with that sometimes if they've
had extensive liposuction and having a
little difficulty healing we'll use it
in those cases
sometimes if we see an infection
sometimes infections are very difficult
to treat especially if they get in the
implant
themselves like a breast implant or a
chin implant and if we
you know those are almost impossible to
to heal without removing the implant
but sometimes if we can put them in the
hyperbaric oxygen chamber
get a higher concentration oxygen there
we can actually heal them
and spare them from having to remove
their implant and spare them from
further surgery and once again
you know scars heal better when we do
hyperbaric oxygen treatment you know
things heal faster breathing is less
people recover quicker so it's useful
for
for almost any procedure that we do but
particularly for big procedures like a
mommy makeover which is a big procedure
give smith plastic surgery a call at
right here on las 702-838-2455 now